my level I'm
oning
on when the person to do
something that
so you can't mechanically work out so
all the stages you're going to go
through you will get better and better
and better
technique so you we start going up and
then coming down a bit close I push
myself
away and if I was a bit more clumsy i'
push J and I would go away until until
go away and so we go through all these
different
phases until
means that Jenny doesn't know what angle
I'm working she'll think I'm actually
working at this angle that's where she's
pushing I'm actually working
towards yeah I'm nearly used to your
name we come together I come here even
I'm
coming first did right so I I added that
in
there so just by thinking of
La so until you react you won't feel a
Direction but it's
it's but you know
or you break you break the so last time
you weren't all here but last
time
here so I'm going to come here and
here's
my I'm to come here and I'm I got
straight on if I come in too
quick then it's a block
so what I've got to do is I've actually
got
go this is what we
call this what you're looking for you're
looking this
and the key is not to bring it
in to give it
out
so don't do this and then bring it
in that's the difference between
using come here take it out to the
wall has a different feeling on my
partner it's
it could
be it can be called lots of things the
the action is
Road said all techniques become
Road and then from here my hand turn it
this way
see my hand
spiral the spiral
is the spiral ends